dr gaurav ahuja
will be talking on evolving role of
bioinformatics and universities and
research labs in india
i would like to introduce him he is uh
he has graduated
sama kam laurie from the university of
colombia germany with a phd in natural
sciences
and after his completion of his phd
degree he worked as a postdoctoral
fellow at several renowned institutions
including the center for molecular
medicine max planck institute for aging
and the kong khan school of medicine
singapore he has published 14 research
articles in peer-reviewed international
journals with approximately 250
citations in addition to this he has
also reviewed articles submitted to
nature publishing group
cell death and diseases and scientific
reports to be more specific and recently
dr ahuja was shortlisted for prestigious
inspired faculty fellowship
we are pleased to have you with us sir
over to you
uh hi thank you i mean can you
hear me i mean anybody can please
confirm if you guys can yes sir yes we
can hear you thank you and now let me
quickly
share my screen as well
i hope my screen is visible
yes that's visible i can see the zoom
yeah i can see your presentation now
great so i think thank you by the way
thank you for the whole pine bio team
for having me today and also thank you
for all the participants to spare some
time to listen to my
you know experience i would say rather
so i mean while i mean when i started
when i got this invitation i was a
little bit confused
it was not a confusion like what i'm
going to share with you guys but the
confusion was more like whether i could
share with you the science
which we are doing in the lab which is a
little bit boring for all of you
or
on the other hand i would rather share
with you
the futuristic goals like how i meant
you know shape up my career in you know
bioinformatics or you can say
computational biology
and how basically you know we train in
our department because our department
triple it delhi is one of the you know
top most departments where we have a
dedicated programs for computational
biology so i was thinking like many of
you may be
looking for opportunities or some sort
of guidance
from where you can do a dedicated
program in computational biology what
are the courses they teach how it is
different from bioinformatics even if i
can do a master's or bachelor's or a phd
in computational biology what are my
futuristic you know
what what i will do after my phd for
instance so there are some of the things
i thought like i should rather combine
all these instead of boring you guys
with the science which i do in my lab so
nevertheless i once again i'm gaurav i'm
a assistant professor at the triple i t
delhi so it is very small but a very
beautiful institute in the center of
delhi
and yeah i mean primarily as you can see
from the name it's the information
technology so it's the id institute but
normally you know we have mixed
everything with it for instance like we
have computer science we have computer
science with biology we have courses for
the you know computer science with
social science so everything is mixed
with the flavor of computer science that
is what i will say is very unique to
triple it delhi let me give you a brief
glimpse about who i am what i i was one
among you guys like today you know you
guys are here i mean almost like 10
years back 12 years back i was sitting
at your side and i also used to listen
to not online though but offline but i
was also one of the academic enthusiasts
like one of you because you you guys are
sparing your time
listening to the experts in the field i
i also did that when i was a student so
i just want to give you a very brief
glimpse
like you know i started with bsc in
biotechnology from jamia mille islamiyah
it's a university in delhi after that i
did masters in genomics from madurai
camaraderie
then i got some sort of international
scholarship i went to germany from the
institute of genetics cologne i did my
phd and also a little bit post-op over
there then i moved to the c-cad cmmc and
max planck institute where i did my
three years post-doc then i was in a lee
kum chang school of medicine and i was
in sync it was in singapore i did a you
know another senior postdoc and in the
middle of 2019 i started my own group i
just wanted to make a point here is when
i started my group my age was 29 so the
first faculty offer which i got it from
inspire faculty in 2019
i was 28 and a half or 29 years old and
i declined that offer
because i i mean there are multiple
reasons for that scientific ones but i
just wanted to tell you guys one thing
when so you know you guys are building
your career you're trying to build your
career now so if you do compromises with
the science at this stage
for example you know for every
researcher the faculty job is one of the
dreams anyone can look for and it was
really hard for me when i declined this
offer because i was not sure
whether next year i will get something
similar or not
but i still took the
chance i declined it because i know
i mean i know the power of the science i
know what i was doing and luckily enough
within another one year i got a faculty
offers from two institutes and i joined
delhi because i am basically i belongs
to delhi so i wanted to be in delhi so i
joined triplet delhi in july and then
afterwards the things got changed we got
a number of you know we got three four
brands money-wise in india if you do
bioinformatics if you do you know at
least for i mean my lab is a sort of
hybrid lab we do experimental biology we
also do you know computational biology
both of the like we do 60 40 so in all
the cases like the funds is not never
been a bottleneck at least for the last
two years
my i'm doing science in india just
wanted to make another point here from
2010 until 2019 mid i was never being
exposed to the indian science
and i will tell you i really thoroughly
enjoying doing science in india
at least in triplet delhi the reason
being the institute is supportive the
people are supportive and the overall
ambiance really allows you to you know
flourish to do great in science that is
something triple id provides us
now without boring you much that's the
only slide about science from the lab so
my lab works on smell i mean you know
the sense of smell we use r we use
python i was listening to professor
sharma she was you know insisting about
learning r and python these are the you
know
two big languages which are commonly
been used in data science so we we use
on routine basis both of them because
you know when we
in my lab for example i have six phd
students you know 12 interns so total
the lab length is around you know size
is around 20 people in the group
some people have a innate preference for
python and some people have an innate
preference for r and also there are
people like who are more you know
comfortable with python but sometimes
for certain packages they like r so they
do you know shifting between left and
right so the best answer is to learn
both of them
and you know there are multiple ways for
instance you like the interface of
python and you just want to run one
package of r there are multiple
libraries you can basically use one and
you call the function of the other one
example is reticulate library you can
really do
you know r codes python codes in r and
so far and so on so you can really
interchange between them now we also do
you know study about evolution in the
lab so there are some biological
problems we solve related to evolution
then we also do as i said i have a
hybrid lab i am fortunate to be funded
by triple i t delhi department of
biotechnology government of india from
the dst as well as from sub my lab is
funded so we do also do some sort of
molecular biology
and
not just last but not the least we also
do you know we walk with east as a model
organism so that is all about my science
so let me introduce you to the place
which you guys may intend to do your you
know that's one of the i will say one of
the most
you know
you know one of the most prestigious
institute if in india if you're looking
for a computational biology course let
me put it as a case study and let me you
guys introduce you to our department at
the center of computational biology
here this is our institute this is one
of the building i just put it like just
to excites you so we are small this is
not something we all have we have
multiple other buildings but this is the
central one the first one and the old
one so this is our academic block there
we have lecture hall and you know at the
corner of somewhere here i we have our
experimental lab and on the right side
we have a research and developmental
block where we have you know our dry lab
which we say you know computational
biology labs so this is a glimpse of our
institute very beautiful neat and clean
but a little bit small compared to if
you talk about iit delhi if you talk
about compare with jnu and other
universities we are very small but
cleanness wise and also you know
productivity wise we are really you know
ahead now
this is our department i think there are
multiple people you guys i mean why i
wanted to introduce you to all of them
because that gives you a glimpse
like what is a core computational
biology department now some of the
students may be thinking and may be
wondering
like why there is intermix between a
computational biology and bioinformatics
i mean i think this is always a tool
which is used by many people especially
the people who are in the computational
field they some people like to call
themselves as a computational biologist
rather than bioinformatician because
they think i mean they really think
bioinformaticians are the ones who
basically use the tools they use the
packages they use the pre-cooked hard
work of somebody else and they just do
the data analysis so that is i i don't
want to go into this fights between
whether you call yourself as a
bioinformatician or you call yourself as
a computational biologist because i
always believe the things needs to be
done it should be done irrespective
whether you are using package or you are
rebuilding the room that is all depends
upon you so we have this wonderful
colleagues in the department so i start
with you know professor gps i think he
was also one of the persons who was
invited by
pine bio for delivering a lecture he is
one of the pioneers in india in the
field of bioinformatics he has got
multiple awards he has published so many
bioinformatic papers having multiple
servers open source platforms he
contributed so he is heading our
department we have the bhakta sengupta
he is a trained com you know computer
scientist i just wanted to say his
training was you can see like here you
know his phd was in computer science
with a you know some portion of the
biological data but he is trained as a
computer scientist
now we have arjun ray he is also my
colleague he is basically a biophysicist
he works with the protein modeling so
this is another dimension so think about
it like this is our department
so professor raghwa being senior being
experienced he is basically mentoring
everything we have the barca saying
gupta he has expertise from the computer
science we have arjun ray he's a
biophysicist
same with ganesh pagler he's more into
network biology and he's also a
physicist by training and doing biology
now it's me i mean my phd is in genetics
i as i said i i'm a trained genomist you
know that is what me filling the gaps
now we have just pre he's basically she
works on chemo informatics we have
vibhur kumar he works with so so he is
m.tech from iit delhi phd from
sneaky and you know and he is basically
experienced with you know
uh your
epigenetics we have tapritesh he's a
medical doctor and he also did phd after
mbbs and he works with the health
healthcare system and all that we have
shiri ram he is a mathematician by
training so he use mathematics to make
models to understand the biological
system and now recently we have been
lucky enough to get professor murugan
who was a associate professor in the kth
in stockholm and recently joined our
department now having said these things
so you know and he's ex he's a phd from
isc bangalore and he works with you know
chemistry pure chemistry now this is the
vision of our department so the vision
of our department is to create a to
become a leading center in the country
to for developing the mathematical and
the computational techniques for
understanding the biological system
so think about it like if
so you know we are not that sort of
department where you have you know you
know faculty members who are trained in
biology learned bioinformatics and
teaching you no the department is
crafted in such a manner each and every
person in the department has
is bringing a orthogonal dimension
which basically is necessary you know
super important to do interdisciplinary
research which is the prerequisite for
computational biology
now just wanted so these are all the
names these are basically from where
these people are now just quickly so
what we teach what courses we cover as a
part of our computational biology course
so we have i mean this is something
which i'm showing you for you know the b
tech and the m tech so we have
foundations of biology because there are
multiple people we get in our institute
they are not from biological background
so but they still want to learn you know
computational biology so we have a
foundation course so that they can have
a feeling of biological system so that
because in the foundations of biology we
also introduce them to the quantitative
biology a little bit mixture of
mathematics
with biology so that they can better
train for the next step we also have a
hardcore cell biology and biochemistry
we also have genetics and we also have
molecular biology for them
we have algorithms so we also teach so
there are dedicated core courses for the
algorithms in the computational biology
because you know that i mean you know in
case you are using a tool it's fine but
in case you want to make a tool you
should have a better understanding of
the algorithms so we teach them the core
algorithms which have been used or which
may be used in computational biology so
we have a dedicated course for that we
have a network biology course we have
chemo informatics we have systems and
synthetic biology course we have
computational neuroscience we have a
course in the data science in genomics
we have dedicated courses for the
machine learning for the biomedical
applications big data mining in
healthcare you know simulations and
systems biology network science
biostatistics and statistical
computations so these are some of them
we you know once you are in our
department every student irrespective
whether you are a bachelor student you
are a master student or you are a phd
student you will be given the choices to
you know attend any of the elective
courses so triple it hosts a lot of
elective courses we have hardcore
mathematical courses we have applied
mathematics for statistics i can say we
have five different courses for
statistics each of them is very
specialized for instance i used to teach
you know biostats so it is more about
you know using r to you know do
descriptive statistics as well as
influential statistics with the
biological data but in case you are more
interested in more hardcore statistics
you can easily you know opt for some
other courses so every possibility is
being provided by the department to the
students
now moving a little bit more forward
what courses triple id delhi
computational biology department offers
you so we are a very young department we
started in 2017
and you know we have a phd in
computational biology we have amp tech
course in computational biology which is
funded by dvd and aicte so it which
means that if you are opted for a m tech
in computational biology so dbt funds
you dbt funds you for your you know you
get some sort of small stipendia or
stipend and apart from that you also get
you know
some contingency money for your thesis
and all that so it is this program is
supported by the dvd and you also get a
little bit money to do some sort of
experiments you want to buy something so
all these support we get from the dbt
and aicte
now we also offer a beat tech course but
there is a caveat the caveat is the beta
course is not computational biology we
call it a c s plus b
plus b is normally it is a tailored
course for computer science
so all the courses which a computer
science graduate is basically
or the you know undergrad is basically
learning you will also have the same
courses
but at the same time you will have
additional courses which is the bio
related courses so that's why we call it
as btec in csb csb is for computer
science and biology so that is the btec
program
now we have beta in computational
biology minor i mean i will if somebody
has questions we can take into account
so we also provide post-doctoral
training a lot of postdocs are there in
our department we also have external
interns for example in all my colleagues
lab even in my lab we get people from
other institutes so if any one of you
looking for internship want to
contribute to or want to learn
contribution is too early i think it
depends but if you want to learn you
know get your hands dirty with you know
computational biology you are most
welcome to work as intern we have the pg
diploma students as well triple i t has
a joint data science program with ibm so
we also
basically the faculty members from the
department also teaches to the you know
this pg diploma students so this is the
curricular activities provided by the
department now a little bit more forward
what is the strength of our department
so the basic the core strength of our
department is
we
offer holistic interdisciplinary and
active learning approach
we
are very intensive for computationally
and programming you know all our courses
are really intensive for computationally
as well as programming so you how why
i'm saying this because for instance in
our bachelor's and master's program
before the students joins the department
we normally have you know a training
like we call it as preparatory module we
really teach them the programming skills
so that whenever they the real session
starts semester starts they are well
equipped with the jargons of programming
we have a lot of mathematical courses as
i said to make the students you know
comfortable and strong with basic
mathematics which is required to do any
cutting edge work we also have intensive
biology courses including the laboratory
because you know as dr sharma was also
mentioning like every computational
biologist they also produce data because
that is something the need of the r is
so the department recognized over the
years it's easy i mean it was all good
like the my our students were analyzing
data they were you know building
algorithms they were basically making
softwares but at the same time it was
really important to teach them because
you know b-tech and m-tech programs are
the learning programs
so during this time it will be really
nice if they can know i mean they can
have some images like you know
some sort of microscopic images you know
our students take few minutes or two
days to you know develop a very
sophisticated architecture to do deep
learning
deep learning architect but the point is
if they don't understand from where this
image is coming
then it is there is no sense of doing
that so that's why the departments
thought it's better to have a dedicated
laboratory and from the help of dbt we
set up a fully functional experimental
laboratory interplay denali we also as i
said we do special preparatory modules
for bio computing so we call it as for
bio computing we also provide research
and industrial internships now
apart from this we also you know
organize a lot of scientific talks blah
blah blah there are so many things the
department also offers core courses a
lot of elective courses and also course
these departmental courses you can opt
for instance you are m tech student in
our department in our department and you
are also interested in a special course
for example that is provided by the
social science department
if you have the liberty being
interpolated you can offer close
departmental elective courses you are
allowed to do that now we also do pg
diploma now our faculty expertise as i
said it's very diverse we have faculties
experts in bioinformatics mathematics
and computing chemo informatics medicine
or health informatics structural biology
genomics molecular biology biophysics
aiml for health
so
quickly think about you know research
innovation and extension very slowly i'm
telling you so it is the data for the
last year so the last year the total
citation come to our department all i
mean we are 10 faculty members in total
we got got around 4 000 citations there
were 63 publications came out
you know from our department this is not
the total impact factor this is the
average impact factor it is not total
it's wrong
so
now on the other hand applied research
so we have developed seven databases 26
web servers and three mobile
applications within one year in terms
about innovation our department has made
a technology transfer which means you
know we talk about bioinformatics
research so me and my colleague debarka
sengupta we developed something back in
2019 and the we give it to the inst we
patented it and the patent we sold it to
a private company i will be talking
about it next like how you make a
transition being a data scientist you
develop something and then you basically
there are people who are interested in
that product and then you can do the
technology transfer we did that and
during pandemic there are multiple
things the department has done four of
them are there now there are multiple
faculty colleagues because they are very
aggressive in their research we have two
startups from our department and we also
have a pg diploma program which is ibm
triple ii delhi
so these are some glimpse about our
department how vibrant how dynamic we
are in terms of computational biology
research now as i said we also have a
lot of infrastructure so infrastructure
wise it's not a problem i just give you
one example so my own lab i mean it is
one among ten labs in triple id alley my
whole lab has four personal servers i
have my four servers which has a i mean
if
i tell you in terms of ram we have more
than one tb of ram for like six phd
students so we are very generously
funded by government of india different
agencies also by the institute and you
know these are the common facility which
we have so the upper one and the lower
one these are the institute it's not an
institute department uh you know
department also have their own servers
so these are the departmental servers
but each and every faculty member have
their own personalized servers as well
now
as i said these are just the equipment
some of the equipments i put it from the
experimental lab which we have qpcrs
western blots we have spectrophotometer
multi-channel floral floors and plate
readers we have i mean you think of
something except sequencer we have most
of the equipment and mass spectrometer
we have most of the equipment and we are
planning to purchase that as well in the
near future
now
i just want to make a case study you
know
of computational biology in india so as
i said we have made a technology
transfer and it was brought up it led to
the you know uh generation of k ronko
biotech so this was the research carry
forward by the baka san gupta my
colleague in the department and myself
so we did that we you know patented this
technology and it is now basically been
validated for more than 400 patients and
you know we are soon going in the indian
market as a liquid biopsy test for
cancer so let me introduce you guys and
there is there i stopped so what
basically happened is dibaka one of my
colleagues so he basically came to me in
when i recently joined triple a denali
with some of the complex problems
because he was trying to solve the
tumor-educated platelet so each one of
you know like your body has platelets
but people eventually over the years
recognize the platelets in our body
get tailored or get you know transformed
if there is a cancer in the body so the
point is if there is a cancer the cancer
can be sensed by the platelets in the
body and you can isolate the platelets
and then you can screen for the bio
markers in the platelets you can able to
detect the presence of cancer so this is
called liquid biopsy like we do solid
biopsy we you know the doctor do the
surgery they take the piece pieces
they take a
piece of the tissue solid tissue they
call it as tissue biopsy in the same way
either you can take urine you can take
saliva you can take blood and then you
are basically looking for cancer it
comes under liquid biopsy so we
developed this tumor educated platelets
and now it is a part of kieran co we are
one of the founding member you know the
co-scientific co-founders of kieran go
biotech private limited in new delhi
now so this is the team this is the
bikers in gupta so
he is the one and and it's me uh gaurav
is ashok juneja
mitra our ceo avinash malotra we have
wonderful ladies in our you know these
things so this is all about us now
what is the burden of cancer so
the late detection so so one of the
problem with the cancer is we detect the
cancer late
and you know late detection leads to
high mortality
now the cancer burden
is we know that there are 19.3 million
people die because of cancer every year
and the reason for that is the cancer is
detected late
75 of the cancers has always been
detected late and since it is detected
late there is a high mortality a lot of
people die and also if you detect the
cancer late if you want to do the you
want to cure the patient
you have to do chemotherapy radiations
and
immunotherapies so the overall cost is
really high
so
what we developed in triple it delhi so
triple iet delhi we developed a essay
which can be done in 2.5 hours and there
is a lot of ai involved so there is i'm
see doing a qpcr is not a problem
because you know qpcr is just a simple
steps any any time they can hurry with a
training of two
weeks can able to do qpcr and due thanks
to this covet because everybody's know
about qpcr how it is done so we have not
done any rocket science in this part we
have done the rocket science mainly in
ai so we have developed with the help of
you know computational biology training
we have developed the ai based platform
where you project the ct values coming
from the platelets of the you know any
patient healthy patient as well as the
tumor patient we
we applied a algorithm called copula you
can read about it and it is one one of
the nicest you know
method to basically do the
classification as well as to do the
batch correction so we applied that and
then we basically implemented the ai
algorithms and we basically can classify
the
you know tumor patients as well as the
healthy cohorts with the accuracy around
more than 90
and to be honest there is no method to
date which can achieve this much high
sensitivity as well as high specificity
so we are the one of the upcoming
methods which are your astonishingly
very high sensitivity as well as
specificity
this was our paper so the entire you
give us the blood we do the testing we
give the report and the whole procedure
takes around 2.5 hours that's all
and you know
i mean if you see the other
players in the market like there are
people who do liquid biopsy but they
require 25 ml of the blood the problem
is
the cancer if you are cancer patient
and if you are trying to measure the
relapse of cancer you cannot give them
25 ml of the blood so all the other
methods available in the market they
require high volume of blood 15 to 25 ml
but our method works with the 6 ml of
bloods
it can detect 10 plus you know cancers
you don't need anything it just
basically works with the normal
molecular biology lab we can detect
stage one cancer as well accuracy is
around 94 percent and it's very
affordable
so it's 100 to 150 dollars you can
really do the testing
so i mean i haven't talked about signs
sorry for that but these are all the
just the glimpse of papers i was able to
get it from triple i t delhi in the last
two years from my lab
as either the senior author or the
corresponding author from the lab so
these are the journals where we
published in the last two years
with that i would like to thank my team
my phd students
a lot of my you know we have you know a
junior
research engineer who is basically doing
the lab management in nilesh we have the
previous students from the lab for
example siddhant
he was the mtech student so now he's in
the us doing his phd
we have riya she was a b-tech student
did her project with me
and now she got a job in google working
for the google india
brenda she is also a b-tech student
worked in our group now she is working
in
microsoft india
sidra she got a phd she was a m tech
student now she is a phd in
akram in germany
radhika she is doing job in india she
was my m tech student all my
collaborators
and thanks to the funding agencies and
thank you to each one of you thank you